in the 6th episode of Star Trek Picard
jean-luc Picard in the crew of the Lhasa
Rana reached the Beauregard effect and
Shoji finally begins to learn the truth
about who and what she is from voyager
nods to visuals pulled straight from
deep space 9 here are all the Easter
eggs and references in the impossible
box early on in the impossible box says
the loss of renin ears the former Borg
cube known as the artifact Picard
instructs a computer in his study to
search for the terms the artifact treaty
and the Borg when he sits down to
reluctantly scroll through the results
several of the images on which Picard
chooses to linger are easily
identifiable
there's the export hue both when he
first came aboard the enterprise on the
next generation and then again as he
appears in Picard several shots of X
Borg in the midst of the reclamation
procedures and of course Picard is
Locutus of Borg but there are several
other quick glimpses of search results
you may not have recognized the first
was a shot of a federation ship firing
on a Borg cube and seemingly doing some
damage which could have been from the
battle at the opening of Star Trek first
contact the next images of the Romulan
continuing committee which is taken
straight from the Deep Space nine
episode in which a character becomes
entangled in a tall Shiar plot there is
also a brief image of the Paris skyline
in the year 23 72 which was taken from
the Deep Space nine Episode two the
death in that episode the ds9 crew has
to destroy an iconian gateway a
technological portal which could
instantly transport people over enormous
distances which is very similar to the
device Picard and Shoji used to escape
the Romulans at the end of the
impossible box as the Lasseter Ana nears
the Borg artifact
Rafi turns on the charm to contact her
old friend in Starfleet contact Amy
requesting diplomatic credentials for
Picard
but Emmy refuses at first saying that
the Romulans are in a 250-year bad mood
if you're wondering what happened to the
Romulans two and a half centuries ago to
make them so cranky well that's about
the time they first came in contact with
humans in 2150 - just a few years later
in 2156 the earth Romulan war began
which only lasted for four years but is
still having repercussions over 200
years into the future the end of the war
was marked by the establishment of the
Romulan neutral zone in 2160 and led
directly to the formation of the United
Federation of Planets in 2161 given the
Romulans long
tension with the Federation it's no
wonder that they're still in a bad mood
when hue mentions in the impossible box
that the former Borg on the artifact
refer to themselves as X B's Picard
wanders out loud at the reason for
renaming themselves Hugh explains a new
name can be the first step to a new
identity those years ago the lesson he
was referring to took place in the
episode where he first appeared on the
next generation titled a Borg at first
Hugh doesn't see himself as an
individual but as a member of the
collective referring to himself only as
we and telling the crew that he is third
of five however after Geordi and Beverly
explained the purpose of names to him he
decides he wants one for himself - I
have a name do you want one a name
adopting his own name marks the
beginning of Hugh's ability to think of
himself in terms of I not we and
ultimately leads to his lifelong mission
to free and rehabilitate other Borg in
part Hugh's job is the executive
director of the Borg reclamation project
involves him overseeing the
rehabilitation efforts of the
traumatized ex board who are trying to
recuperate from their assimilation
however as he shares with the card even
after the XPS have gone through
reclamation they still aren't accepted
by free society Hugh says that the XPS
remain the most hated people in the
galaxy just as helpless and enslaved as
before but that now their queen is a
Romulan this is a clear nod to the Borg
Queen that record himself encountered in
Star Trek first contact the Queen was
the one who directed the Borg's actions
and she revealed in first contact that
it was her idea to assimilate Picard his
Locutus rather than have just another
nameless Borg drone the Queen had hoped
Picard would service or counterparts
however Picard's resistance proved not
to be futile after all forcing the Queen
to abandon her plan when Picard finds
shoji alive on the artifact it's great
news for the two of them but not so good
for Rafi who had placed a bet with Rios
that the cards target would already be
dead you owe me two strips of land
twins to the life while latinum has
popped up here and there across multiple
Star Trek shows it was most frequently
mentioned in deep space 9 is the
preferred currency of the Ferengi
alliance and specifically of quark the
Ferengi bartender on the space station
Platinum is often referenced in the
Ferengi rules of acquisition around
which Ferengi society is structured
nature decays latinum lasts forever
timber 102 good
when Picard and you enter Sochi's
quarters a voice can be heard in the
background announcing that sectors 5 8
to 5 21 are temporarily closed due to
detected chronometric activity in Star
Trek first contact the controlled
emission of chrono metric particles is
what allowed the board to travel back in
time and assimilate earth which force
the Enterprise crew to chase after them
and re-establish the original timeline
but in addition to the chrono metric
activity the specific sectors that are
mentioned may also have a hidden meaning
in the fifth season of Star Trek The
Next Generation Episode eight and
episode 21 were both directed by cliff
bolt while neither of these episodes
feels particularly relevant to the
impossible box the same cannot be said
of the two other bull directed episodes
of the next generation the best of both
worlds parts 1 & 2 those of course are
the episodes in which Picard is
assimilated by the Borg and becomes
Locutus an event which was heavily
referenced in the impossible box when
Picard Sol G Hugh and Eleanor find
themselves trapped in the former Borg
Queen's Chamber he was able to use his
collective memories of the area to grant
them access to the queen's fail-safe
escape route it turns out the Queen has
a spatial trajector an incident
teleportation device with a wide range
which you says was built from technology
the Borg required after assimilating
Zakarian's Star Trek fans have actually
seen a spatial trajector once before on
the Star Trek Voyager first season
episode prime factors in the episode
Captain Janeway in her crew encounter
the Sicari ins whose teleportation
technology has the potential to cut
their decades-long journey home in half
I've just been to alas tria and back
last Rhea is 40,000 light-years away
however the SU Koreans are reluctant to
share their technology due to their own
version of the prime directive which
prohibits them from interfering in the
development of less advanced cultures
sadly it seems that the technology
the Koreans were so protective up in
voyager has since been taken out of
their hands by force
although picard was certainly grateful
for the escape he'd probably be the
first to agree that the cost was too
high
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
Star Trek are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the BAL so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]